[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
in man observations on the distribution
of traits in families or Kindred's the
so called pedigree pattern is the main
method of genetic study since critical
matings cannot be made by design the
human geneticist must rely on
collections of families for information
relating to Mendel's to laws that of
segregation and that of independent
assortment the pedigree method may also
provide information on the two related
matters of allele ISM and linkage single
factor inheritance is studied by
pedigree patterns study of a particular
trait in a family usually begins with an
affected person who is referred to as
the proband or the Pro+ or sometimes as
the index case and is indicated by an
arrow in pedigree charts males are
represented by squares and females by
circles
although the astrological Mo's are
preferred by some marital lines are
indicated thus and double lines are used
if the mating is consanguineous as for
example between first cousins usually
persons with the trait in question are
indicated by filled in symbols more
complicated devices can be used to
indicate the presence of multiple traits
or to indicate the several
manifestations of a single syndrome
traits and rare diseases of man are
distributed in families in
characteristic patterns which are in
accordance with Mendel's law of
segregation the specific pattern is
dependent on whether the responsible
gene is located on one of the autosomes
or on an x chromosome it is also
dependent on whether the gene in single
dose that is in heterozygous state
suffices to produce the phenotype under
study or whether the gene must be
present in double dosage or homozygous
state for development of the trait
traits observable in the heterozygous
person are termed dominant whereas those
which occur only in persons homozygous
for the given gene are termed recessive
autosomal dominant inheritance is
illustrated by the Kindred with
brachydactyly studied by therapy soon
after the rediscovery of Mendel ISM the
trait occurs in successive generations
since it is a rare condition only one
parent has it among the offspring of a
man or a woman with bracket actally on
the average half the sons and half the
daughters are affected this result is
expected when the responsible gene is
located on one of a pair of autosomes
since only one of each pair is
contributed to a given offspring by the
affected parent the chromosome given to
a child may with equal likelihood be
either the one bearing the mutant gene
for brachydactyly or the one bearing the
normal or wild-type gene classical
achondroplastic dwarfism also behaves as
an autosomal dominant trait the family
shown here is of particular interest
because an achondroplastic woman bore
three children each by a different
husband two of the three children were
affected dominant traits tend to show
rather wide variability the degree of
severity is referred to as the
expression of the trait when the
expression is reduced to the point that
persons with the gene cannot be
distinguished from those without it then
the trade is said to be non penetrant
expression of a dominant trait as
observed in a large series of cases is
described by a bell-shaped curve the
largest number of cases have an
intermediate grade of severity some are
very severe some very mild these
variations may be the effects of
modifier genes and Biron mental factors
also influence the expression of gene
action like dominant traits autosomal
recessive
rates such as albinism affect both males
and females usually both parents are
phenotypically normal but both are
carriers that is heterozygous for the
mutant gene in question and by special
tests may show mild abnormality
since related individuals are more
likely to be heterozygous for the same
rare mutant gene consanguineous matings
are more likely to result in offspring
affected by a recessive trait the more
rare the recessive trait the higher is
the proportion of parental matings which
are found to be consequent yes for a
rare condition such as albinism the
proportion of parents who are first
cousins may be as high as 10% and much
higher consonantal rates have been
observed with even rarer traits in the
case of very rare recessive disorders
parental consanguinity may be the first
clue to its inherited nature among the
offspring of two heterozygous parents
the risk of any one child's being
homozygous and affected is one in four
the chance of being heterozygous is two
in four or one-half and the chance of
being free of the mutant gene is one in
four shown here is the pedigree of an
inbred kindred in which seven cases of
the Kriegler Najjar syndrome have
occurred in three related subjects
jaundice is a leading feature of this
syndrome an inborn defect in the
excretion of bilirubin it is inherited
as an autosomal recessive in one section
of this pedigree
studies showed that heterozygotes have a
reduced ability to conjugate bilirubin a
second autosomal recessive disorder the
more quia syndrome also occurred in this
kindred
if an individual affected by a recessive
trait marries a homozygous normal person
none of the children will be affected
but all will be heterozygous carriers if
an individual affected by a recessive
trait marries a heterozygote then the
expectation is that half the children
will be affected the pedigree pattern
superficially resembles autosomal
dominance previously there were thought
to be two types of alkaptonuria a more
common form inherited as a recessive and
a rarer form inherited as a dominant
this pedigree of alkaptonuria suggested
autosomal dominant inheritance however
on closer study it was found that in at
least two successive generations
affected persons married a relative it
is likely that the normal spouse was in
each case a heterozygote and the
inheritance is indeed recessive
dominance and recessive nesara of course
attributes of the trait not of the gene
as a matter of convenience however
geneticists sometimes speak of a
dominant gene or a recessive gene some
traits are determined by genes carried
on the X chromosome and are called
sex-linked or more precisely x-linked
such traits have the characteristic the
transmission from father to son does not
occur this follows directly from the
fact that the X chromosome in the male
is transmitted to none of the sons but
is transmitted to every daughter in
females x-linked traits may be either
dominant or recessive again depending on
whether the phenotype is observable in
the heterozygote or only in the
homozygote however in males who with
only one x chromosome are homozygous
x-linked rates are regularly expressed
rare x-linked recessive disorders occur
almost exclusively in males the
condition though not expressed in
heterozygous females is transmitted by
them to half their sons
among the children of an affected male
none of the sons is affected but all the
daughters are heterozygous carriers if
an affected male marries a heterozygous
carrier then a daughter may be
homozygous and hence affected note that
in such families an affected male may
also occur but this is not an exception
to the rule of no male-to-male
transmission since the affected male
inherited the trait through the mother
hemophilia is the textbook example of an
x-linked recessive trait but pseudo
hypertrophic muscular dystrophy colour
blindness and more than 50 other traits
are known to be inherited in this manner
in the case of x-linked dominant traits
such as vitamin D resistant rickets
heterozygous females are affected as
well as hemizygous males an affected
female transmits the trait to have her
sons and half her daughters just as for
an autosomal dominant trait however an
affected male transmits it to none of
his sons and to all of his daughters
thus rare x-linked dominant traits occur
about twice as frequently in females as
in males the examples given up to now
illustrate Mendel's first law that of
segregation characteristics such as the
presence or absence of sickle hemoglobin
are distributed in families in
accordance with the process of mitotic
segregation as outlined in the first
film the orphanage genes which determine
different forms of a given trait are
called alleles and occupy identical
positions or low sigh on homologous
chromosomes genes at different loci are
non alleles the distribution of traits
in families may give information on
whether particular genes are allelic or
non allelic alleles segregate
non alleles assort two examples are
drawn from previous film are the genes
for hemoglobin s and hemoglobin C allele
e that is at the same genetic locus a
tentative answer is provided by families
in which one parent has both aberrant
hemoglobins and the other has only
normal hemoglobin in such families it
has been found that all children inherit
either hemoglobin s or hemoglobin C but
to date no child has inherited both and
none has inherited neither hemoglobin s
and hemoglobin C are segregating traits
their genes are by this criterion allele
a are the genes for hemoglobin s and
hemoglobin Hopkins - at the same locus
that is allelic again critical
information is provided by families in
which one parent has both of the
aberrant hemoglobins and the other has
neither in this case it is found that
all four possibilities occur among the
offspring some inherit both aberrant
hemoglobins some inherit neither and
others inherit one or the other here is
illustrated Mendel's second law of
independent assortment the genes for
hemoglobin s and hemoglobin Hopkins two
are non allelic are a different genetic
loci possibly even on different
chromosomes non alleles assort chemical
evidence also gives information on
allele ISM and non allele ISM in keeping
with the current concept of one gene one
polypeptide chain allelic genes
determine variation in the same
polypeptide chain
whereas non allelic genes are concerned
with different polypeptide chains even
though in the same protein molecule thus
hemoglobin s and hemoglobin C are
allelic and have changes in the beta
polypeptide of
globine a whereas hemoglobin Hopkins 2
is non allelic with hemoglobin s and C
and has its change in the alpha chain
the chemical and genetic analyses lead
to the same conclusion
both allele ISM and non allele is Ammar
demonstrated in this instructive
pedigree of congenital deafness or deaf
mute ISM an autosomal recessive trait in
the first two generations two deaf mutes
married and in each case all children
were affected in the third generation
again two deaf mutes married each was
affected by recessive congenital
deafness but all their children were
normal we can conclude that these
parents were homozygous at different
loci this pedigree suggests the
existence of at least two non allelic
genetic varieties of congenital deafness
non allele ISM can also be established
by linkage studies for example in some
families ellipta cytosis is determined
by a gene at a locus close to the locus
for Rh blood groups in other families
ellipta cytosis which at present cannot
be distinguished we know typically is
determined by a gene at a locus not
linked to that for Rh blood group the
genes for the two forms of x-linked
hemophilia classic hemophilia and
christmas' disease are not allelic for
the gene for classic hemophilia is
rather close to the colorblindness locus
whereas the gene for Christmas disease
is located on the X chromosome at a
greater distance from the colorblindness
locus linkage is the occurrence of two
loci on the same chromosome sufficiently
close together that they do not assort
independently if two low Saye are on
separate non-homologous chromosomes then
independent assortment does occur even
if Tolosa are on the same chromosome
pair they may be so far apart for
example one on the long arm and
the short arm of a long chromosome that
independent assortment occurs through
crossing over just as though the low
sigh were on separate chromosomes
information on linkage is provided
mainly by the offspring of a doubly
heterozygous person and a person
homozygous at the same two loci but the
gene in the double heterozygote may be
either in coupling with the two
dominance on one chromosome and the
recessives on the other or in repulsion
with a dominant and a recessive on each
in the two cases the genetic distance
between the Llosa is the same but the
phenotypes of the offspring who result
from crossing over are different linkage
is illustrated by the findings in
sixteen sub ships reported in the
literature in which the two traits
studied were lutheran blood group and
the secretor factor the secretion or non
secretion of [ __ ] blood group substance
into the saliva in each of these
families one parent was doubly
heterozygous and the other homozygous
recessive at both Llosa the genotype of
the parent homozygous recessive at both
low sy can be only the one shown here
however the genotype of the doubly
heterozygous parent can be either in
coupling or in repulsion in these data
note the strong tendency for children in
a given family to be in either one class
or the other in those cases in which the
doubly heterozygous parent was in
coupling the children were mainly of the
types on the left side when in repulsion
the children were mainly of the types on
the right side however in each of seven
families there was at least one
exceptional individual for example in
family five four of the five sibs are of
expected types but the fifth must be the
result of a crossover in the doubly
heterozygous parent the same reasoning
applies to the six other families where
the indicated individuals are considered
to be recombinants the total number of
offspring in each
class is about equal thus no clue of
linkage is provided in all 70 children
occurred in these families of these nine
are recombinants and 61 are non
recombinants thus the recombination
fraction Chi is 9 out of 70 or 13% it is
concluded that the Lutheran and secretor
Llosa are on the same chromosome and
about 13 math units apart the lower the
recombination fraction
the closer the two loci are on the
chromosome if the recombination fraction
is 50%
that is if crossover and non crossover
progeny occur with equal frequency then
independent assortment obtains the low
sayare either on separate chromosomes or
far apart on the same chromosome linkage
between markers and rare pathologic
traits can also be investigated however
the pathologic trait should be inherited
as a dominant for example ellipta
cytosis and must be identifiable in the
great majority of persons heterozygous
for the gene in addition to the linkage
of the Rh locus with that for one form
of ellipta cytosis linkage has been
demonstrated between the [ __ ] blood group
locus and the locus for the so-called
nail patella syndrome the low sigh are
thought to be about 10 map units apart
for the study of linkage with these rare
diseases it is necessary to use large
Kindred's and all available data in each
since there are a few of them a method
of choice in linkage analysis makes use
of the principle of maximum likelihood
the chance of the constellation of
findings in the family is computed for
various values of Chi the recombination
fraction that value of Chi which gives
the greatest chance is the maximum
likelihood estimate in the time
consuming and error fraught computations
the assistance of the digital
computer is enlisted it can provide
points for curves such as this derived
from a group of families in which
linkage of the nail patella syndrome and
the [ __ ] blood groups was studied two
important points first linkage is quite
different from blood group and disease
Association the association between
blood group all and peptic ulcer has its
basis in some physiologic peculiarity of
the type old person and not in the
location of genes in the same chromosome
indeed
linkage produces no permanent
Association of traits in the population
the second point linkage must be
distinguished from syndrome or
relationship in the Marfan syndrome
dislocated lenses in the eye long
extremities and weakness of the aorta
occur together
however coincidences do in this and most
hereditary syndromes to the fact that
one gene has widespread effects and not
due to close linkage of several separate
genes because of the recombination
between homologous chromosomes through
crossing over even traits due to closely
linked genes are found randomly combined
after the passage of a number of
generations
the objective of linkage studies is to
map the chromosomes of man in as
detailed a manner as has been achieved
for Drosophila and for the mouse after
two loss I have been demonstrated on the
same chromosome it still remains to be
shown which autosome carries this
particular linkage cytogenetic
approaches may help localize specific
genes to specific chromosomes or parts
of chromosomes in the case of x-linked
rates linkage seeks to answer the
question how far apart are two loci the
answer is provided by the proportion of
recombinants among the sons of doubly
heterozygous females here is a tentative
map of the X chromosome showing the
approximate relative position of the
Llosa 4xg blood group glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase deficiency
colorblindness hemophilia a and others
the cornerstone of population genetics
is the hardy-weinberg principle that the
relative frequency of genotypes remains
constant from one generation to the next
unless disturbed by factors such as
mutation selection drift and gene flow
it should be noted that whether a
condition is inherited as a dominant has
nothing to do with its frequency in a
population consider a two allele system
which will indicate as big a for the
dominant gene and little a for its
recessive allele the frequency of the
alleles can be represented by p and q
respectively with p plus q equals 1 the
frequencies of the three genotypes
possible with two alleles are P squared
for big a big a - PQ for big a little a
and q squared for little a little a
Hardy and Weinberg directed thinking
along lines of gene frequency as the
pertinent variable in population
genetics
if one collects from a population all
cases of albinism and autosomal
recessive and finds one case among each
10,000 persons this means a genotype
frequency q squared of 0.0001 Q the
frequency of the gene little a is the
square root of this or 0.01 the
frequency of the dominant allele a is 1
minus 0.01 or point 9 9 note that the
number of heterozygous carriers big a
little a can then be estimated this
value 2 PQ is 2 times 0.01 times 0.99 or
about 0.02 one person in about 50
carries the gene for albinism the
relatively high frequency of carriers of
recessive traits as compared with
affected is demonstrated before
considering the factors which disturbed
the hardy-weinberg equilibrium we should
point out the problem of segregation
analysis of rare recessive traits one
collects families that have at least one
child affected by the trait all of the
affected persons are likely to have two
normal parents both of whom are however
heterozygous for the recessive gene
among the children of two heterozygous
parents 1/4 are affected however when
all SIDS in the ascertained families are
added up it is found that an appreciably
higher proportion than 25% is affected
this is due to bias of ascertain meant
those parents who were both heterozygous
but who were fortunate enough to escape
having an affected child were not
ascertained consider two child families
with both
parents heterozygous for a rare
recessive gene in 16 such families the
first child will be affected in for the
second child will be affected also in 4
out of the 16 but since this is an
independent event one expects that in
only one family will both children be
affected when we undertake to collect
such families in which both parents are
heterozygotes for a rare recessive gene
we can usually recognize only those
families which have at least one child
who is affected of - child families only
7 out of 16 can be ascertained in six of
the seven families ascertained one child
will be affected in one of the seven
both will be affected when we then
assemble the 14 children from the seven
ascertained families we find that eight
are affected and six unaffected whereas
the Mendelian expectation is that
one-quarter of the offspring of two
heterozygous parents will be homozygous
and affected we have found 8 out of 14
or 57% affected if one can be sure that
ascertain Minh tis complete a correction
can be applied to test for agreement
with a fundamental quarter ratio if as
usually obtains ascertain Minh is less
than complete or uncertain other or more
complicated methods of analysis must be
used factors which disturb the
hardy-weinberg equilibrium are drift
gene flow mutation selection genetic
drift is a phenomenon which occurs in
small populations by chance the gene
frequencies in successive generations
may deviate sharply from those in
earlier generations the smaller the
population the greater is the chance of
large random shifts in gene frequencies
genetic drift is nothing more than
sample variance
just as in experimental data the
variance is greater in studies involving
smaller numbers of observations until as
relatively recently is about 7,000 years
ago when agriculture was developed on a
wide scale the human species consisted
of small nomadic hunting groups genetic
drift was probably a potent factor in
changing the genetic Constitution of man
and accounting for Geographic
differences observed today gene flow
results in changes in the genetic
Constitution of populations by adding
new genes through migration contact with
invading armies and miscegenation gene
flow from European to African peoples
has occurred in the United States
through the period of over 300 years
several genes occur in Africans south of
the Sahara in relatively high frequency
but are rare or absent in Europeans
these include a particular Rh type
several other unusual blood groups and a
particular game or globulin type
estimates using these markers indicate
that the present-day American Negro has
about 30% of his genes derived from
European ancestors mutation occurring
during gametogenesis in the parent
generation will of course change at
least very slightly the genotype
frequencies in the offspring generation
mutation is a relatively rare event but
nonetheless provides the raw material of
evolution it is the basis on which
selection and the other factors
discussed here mold the genetic
Constitution of the human species crude
methods for estimating mutation rates in
man are available although such
estimates are subject to many
inaccuracies the rates which have been
determined are of the same order of
frequency as have been found in
experimental forms about one mutation
per locus for 100,000 gametes in other
species three classes of influences have
been demonstrated to cause an increase
in mutation rates
our ionizing radiations chemicals and
heat presumably the same factors operate
in man selection is a fourth factor
which tends to disturb the
hardy-weinberg equilibrium fitness in
the biological or Darwinian sense is
defined in terms of the contribution
made to the genes of the succeeding
generation selection is differential
Fitness according to the genotype of the
organism selection can operate on the
half loyd gamete for example in a
heterozygous male the sperms which carry
one allele may be at a disadvantage as
compared to those which carry the other
furthermore selection can operate on the
diploid organism at any stage from that
of the earliest zygote to the time that
the reproductive span is completed the
clearest example of the operation of a
specific environmental factor in
selection with regard to specific
phenotypes is provided by malaria and
the sickle trait the high frequency of
the sickle gene in some populations
despite the loss of genes in the
homozygous SS person with sickle cell
anemia suggests an advantage of the
heterozygote in these populations
sickling is a polymorphism as defined by
a professor EB Ford the occurrence
together in the same habitat of two or
more forms of a species in such
proportions that the rarest of them
cannot be maintained by recurrent
mutation sickling is furthermore a
balanced polymorphism in some
populations the frequency of the sickle
gene is 0.40
this means that 0.4 squared or 16 per
100 persons have sickle cell anemia and
die at a young age with loss of these
genes the frequency of the sickle gene
would fall from 40 percent to a value
below 5% in 18 generations if it were
not for a balancing factor malaria in
population kills both AAA and sa
individuals early in life but many more
AAA
than sa individuals die the result is
that relatively speaking more si persons
then a a person's survive to reproduce
at equilibrium sickle genes lost in SS
persons are balanced by the sickle genes
saved by advantage of the sa person's
evolution is change in the genetic
constitution of the species the factors
which have been discussed as influencing
gene frequency mutation selection drift
and gene flow are the collaborating
forces in evolution the different
genetic characteristics of the races
which make up the one species man are
the product of these evolutionary forces
[Music]
[Music]